it's a theory a DZ theory to film
spirited might be related surprisingly
even though he's a demigod and she hangs
out with arthropods though they're
sequestered they share ancestors it's a
theory
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory the show where I
go to Hades and back to unearth the
hidden truth behind movies made for
children in Spain of Hades today we turn
to it often overlooked but in my opinion
tragically underappreciated Disney
classic no granted when it first came
out in the late 90s I didn't go to see
it because I was at an age where I was
like Shh I'm too old for Disney movies
all the cool kids are in a Digimon
actually that's complete lie I never
thought I was cool anyway finally
getting around to watching this for the
first time I was really excited about
the cool powers and the Titans and Meg's
killer princess song I gotta admit
though I was a bit disappointed not to
see surah and Sephiroth running around
anyway something in the back of my head
kept niggling away jaegeun eagle it went
something just fell off eagle it
continued but then it hit me the moment
I saw that fun and oh so obvious car
Easter Egg
Hercules is dad is Zeus right Zeus cat
Zeus and that one single and obvious
fact has huge ramifications for
literally every Disney movie you know
and love because if you thought Pixar
had a connected universe well then get
ready because Disney has been doing it
for decades and it all starts with good
ol her because the man who put the glad
and gladiator is a literal blood
relative to perhaps the most popular
Disney Princess of all time I'm talking
fish girl Ariel they are cousins and
that is just the tip of the iceberg my
dear theorists tighten up those togas
because you will never look at the
wonderful world of Disney the same way
again
first to show you how some of Hercules
is immortal blood is also running
through Ariel's gills we have to go a
few branches up his family tree
according to the movie Hercules is the
son of Zeus and Hera and if we're going
by classical mythology standards that's
only partly right first off Hercules is
his Roman name if we're going off of
Greek mythology like literally everyone
else in the movie his name technically
should be Heracles but that name just
doesn't roll off the tongue quite as
nicely so for simplicity's sake I'm just
gonna call our hero by his Roman name
Hercules and the rest of the Gods by
their Greek names like they do in the
movie my apologies to any classics
majors
sensitive years just trying to spread
the good word the other problem is that
era is definitely not Hercules his
loving mother as shown in the movie he
sees ooze was up on Olympus when he saw
and fell in love with a mortal woman
named Alka many so he did what any
rational person would do in such a
situation and disguised himself as elke
Manny's husband who was away at war went
to ELQ Manny's house shouting honey I'm
home and quickly made himself a little
demigod just got a bit awkward when the
real husband came home literally the
next night and his wife was like whoa
you weren't here last night so yeah here
wasn't a big fan of the half son whose
existence was a constant reminder of her
husband's infidelity you know those two
snakes we see baby hercules strangle in
the movie and it's all totally cute well
according to legend those weren't
minions of Hades they were sent by Hera
herself to murder baby hercules in his
crib word the disney doesn't want to
tell you that story for several reasons
but is it really better for zeus to
father Hercules with Hera who according
to mythology is technically his sister
hmm you'd think I'd seen enough Game of
Thrones at this point not to throw up in
my mouth a little when I think about
that but no Hercules in the movie is on
par with prince prick himself at any
rate the important bit here is Hercules
his father which is Zeus both in the
movie and in the myths Zeus is the son
of the Titans Cronus and pray the same
Titans which the muses tell us that he
overthrew at the beginning of the movie
[Music]
Cronus and Rhea had three sons ended up
ruling the three major realms the world
Zeus who ruled over the heavens Hades
ruler of the underworld and Poseidon
ruler of the sea in Hercules we get a
lot of the first two but not so much
abut rest assured he's definitely there
if you look closely according to man's
Poseidon isn't quite as active on tinder
as his brother Zeus but he has a number
of notable children himself like Theseus
the hero kills the Minotaur and Triton
the Merman who serves as trumpeter of
the sea and some of you may be ahead of
me at this point but if you haven't seen
the Little Mermaid in a few years let me
connect the dots for you
Ariel's father the guy who looks like
mermaid Santa Claus is named King Triton
therefore Ariel's grandfather is
Poseidon and her great grandfather is
Cronus - Titan who his grandfather of
Hercules himself put it all together map
out that family tree and we have
Hercules and Ariel as cousins now
prepare yourselves for the twist the
twist is that there is no twist it's cut
dried this isn't a film theory this is a
film fact a mythological fact some might
argue that we have no idea that this
drytown is the same Triton whose nephew
of Zeus but his depiction in little
mermaid matches pretty well the image we
get of him in classical mythology a
bearded half-man half-fish who lives in
a golden palace under the sea no word on
whether that golden palace has the same
power as we got in the original VHS
cover of The Little Mermaid but having
seen my fair share of Greek arts I
wouldn't put it past them
now this is the point in the episode
where you're probably tempted to
subscribe so you should totally do that
stab that subscribe button down below
with your giant Poseidon fork and leave
a comment letting me know what your
favorite Disney movie is in the next
five seconds I'm not gonna do the five
four three two one thing but you know
time it out yourself we'll go on the
honor system here this is also the point
the episode where a lot of you are
probably like yeah you stupid
dinglehopper who cares it's not like
this random little easter egg means
anything for Disney as a whole and you
know what for as much as it hurts me to
be called a fourth I respect your desire
for the deeper meaning of things and in
this case the deeper meaning is that
once you start connecting to Hercules
Little Mermaid lots of other dominoes
start to fall we've already covered some
surprising Disney connections before
like how Elsa from frozen and Rapunzel
from tangled would technically
genetically be twin sisters click right
over here if you missed out on that one
but even if you don't believe that
theory at the very least we see Rapunzel
in the final scenes of frozen meaning
that those two worlds are connected both
in time and place and what we've covered
in today's episode means that we can now
link those two to Hercules as well in
that past episode we mapped out how the
king and queen from frozen egg noir Anna
Doudna were killed when their ship
capsized on their trip from Western
Norway to Germany we don't get the
clearest look at the ship that's
carrying egg nor in a dune ax but from
the shape alone it looks like it could
be the same sunken ship Ariel is looting
at the beginning of Little Mermaid and
geographically it makes a lot of sense
assuming a ganar Anna do know we're
taking a direct route from arendelle and
Western Norway to the northern coast of
Germany their ship likely sank somewhere
off the west coast of Denmark
can you name where the fairy tale The
Little Mermaid is based on comes from
survey says
Denmark number one answer and literally
the only answer because it's just a fact
it's just one answer fact The Little
Mermaid is originally from the works of
hands Christian Andersen a 19th century
Danish author of children's books and
fairy tales
now that doesn't outright prove that
Disney's Little Mermaid is set in
Denmark but we do have other clues
remember Prince Eric's Krusty caretaker
Grimsby
well Grimsby is a Danish name coming
from the name that the Nordic god Odin
would take when he disguised himself as
a human to hit on women side know what
is with the gods dressing up his people
to Mack on human beings you know what
the best pick-up line in the world is
I'm a god I literally control some giant
element of nature you know what if she's
not impressed with that hey she wasn't
worth your time buddy you were too good
for her to begin with
now as new French viewers might argue
that Grimsby is also the name of a town
in northeastern England which is
definitely true but it's also true that
this town was established in the 9th
century AD by Danish Vikings so with all
these clues in place we could be like
99% confidence that Hercules connects
with Little Mermaid tangled and frozen
and if you think this is as far as the
connections go you ain't seen nothing
yet The Little Mermaid also features a
couple of important characters we've
seen in one of Disney's all time
classics late in the movie Prince Eric
is about to marry Ursula and her human
disguise when scuttle and the other sea
creatures crashed the wedding in the
chaos that ensues we see Eric's dog max
run across the screen and for a split
second behind and we can catch a glimpse
of two wedding guests who should look
pretty familiar the king and the Grand
Duke from Cinderella but now we're just
connecting these movies in one long
chain by saying that Hercules is related
to the Little Mermaid and that the
Little Mermaid is related to the rest
surely there's nothing to suggest that a
movie like Cinderella can be connected
back to Hercules a movie about ancient
Greece that was released almost 50 years
later right Oh check this out in an
early scene of Cinderella the king is
complaining to the Grand Duke about how
his son won't settle down and give him
grandchildren for a brief moment we see
that the king has three books on his
desk one by the French Renaissance
author Francois rebel a which makes
sense given that the original version of
Cinderella was by a French author
another by the Greek philosopher Plato
and the last by the Greek poet Homer in
the modern world only two epic poems are
attributed to Homer The Iliad about the
Trojan War and the Odyssey about
Odysseus journey home from the Trojan
War and guess who shows up in both of
those poems Hercules well actually it's
Heracles because Homer was Greek but
we've been over that already
Hercules his ghost meets Odysseus when
the ladder travels to the underworld in
book 11 of the Odyssey and although
Hercules doesn't actively do anything in
the Iliad he's mentioned by name several
times regardless of which book in
particular this is the connections we
talked about today prove that Cinderella
is set in a world in which the stories
of Greek mythology actually exist and
based on the connections we talked about
today we know that those stories aren't
just stories they're not just myths they
really happened in the past and if we
can connect stories seemingly as
unrelated as hercules and cinderella i'd
say it's likely that we're just
scratching the surface here could Elsa's
ice powers have come from an ancient
Greek ancestor good Rapunzel's healing
hair have any relation to Hercules is
the existence of magic in the wonderful
world of Disney somehow tied to all of
these mythological illusions everyone
has known for a long time the careful
attention to detail Disney puts into its
animation but if we can put Hercules The
Little Mermaid tangled throw
and Cinderella all into the same
universe can we really say that any
other Disney movies are outliers there
is no telling how deep this rabbit hole
goes and you can bet that this is a
topic we're gonna continue to explore in
upcoming episodes
so again if you enjoyed this episode
make sure you spear that subscribe
button now if you'll excuse me I have a
few more questions to get answered like
if Triton is Ariel's father what
happened to her mother I think I may
have spotted her and never Neverland but
hey that's just a theory a film theory
and cut hey if you enjoyed this theory
amidst the tangled frozen episode I
mentioned earlier make sure you click on
that one find out how Anna and Elsa
aren't technically sisters or if you're
looking for some more classic Disney
action click the box to the right which
will tell you the truth behind Snow
White's sleeping death it will literally
blow your mind
now if you'll excuse me it's really hot
in my recording closet because it is
just sweltering in California so I need
a drink of water before I pass out